welcome back so now we're ready to
simulate the inverted pendulum on a cart
system and we're ready to stabilize it
using lqr feedback and we're also going
to estimate the full state using a
common filter okay so I'm going to do
this in in stages and I'm also going to
do this using Simulink so I want to kind
of draw out a few things for you so
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to take our real system this
is whatever our system okay and our
system is going to be this inverted
pendulum on a cart so this is actually
easier to simulate the full nonlinear
system in Simulink than it is to write a
script so I'm just going to simulate the
whole system the idea is that we're
going to have some input U and we're
going to have some output X or Y or
whatever so in the first case let's just
say that I have a measurement of the
full state X and what am I going to do
with that well I'm going to pull that
into some lqr regulator which is minus K
X okay so that's what this block is
going to do and we know that we can
stabilize the inverted pendulum on a
cart just using an lqr regulator okay so
in a minute what we're going to do is
we're going to drop this assumption that
we have full access to the full state X
and we're going to put a common filter
estimator block in here but for now
let's just make sure we can do the
linear quadratic regulator and remember
what we're going to be stabilizing about
is the position 0 0 PI 0 okay so that's
X X dot theta theta dot here X is the
the position of the cart this is my
vector X which is all of all of these
states and a vector okay so I'm just
going to show you so first things first
I have my code here that builds a B QR
and my calm and focus are my lqr gain
matrix I'm just going
run this because I have to load this all
on to memory okay and then what I do is
I have this nice Simulink system that I
built and you can download this and play
around with that I'm not going to
explain every single piece but basically
I have this block here cart pend sim and
what this is is this is basically some C
code that simulates the right-hand side
the full nonlinear dynamics of the
system so it's the four OD es we had
before so it takes in U and it outputs
the full state so I'm really measuring
everything and I'm going to give that to
some oscilloscopes so we're going to be
able to plot the four the four states in
time and then what I do is I essentially
split that vector into its four
components so X X dot theta theta dot
and I'm going to do a couple of things
so first thing I have to take theta
minus PI because remember the full
nonlinear system in the pendulum up
position theta is equal to PI but my
calm my lqr regulator is linearized
about that up position so I need to look
in local coordinates theta minus PI
because if I'm a little bit to the right
or the left
I want that to measure is like point 1
or minus point 1 not PI plus point 1 or
PI minus point 1 so I have to I have to
kind of subtract off the equilibrium
from my state of the nonlinear system
and then what I'm going to do is I have
this step here this is kind of cool so I
have this step let me just open it I
have a step at time 10 from 0 to 1 and
so what that's going to do is that's
going to set my equilibrium reference
condition for the cart position X
basically what this is going to say is
that this is going to go to 1 at T
equals 10 ok so the system is going to
start with the pendulum up at x equals 0
at time 0 and then at time 10 it's going
to say well actually I want to be at
position
x equals one and so the controller is
going to have to walk the system over to
x equals one at time 10 and then here
it's a little hard to see but in
Simulink this is literally just I'm
multiplying minus K times the output
here which is my full state X minus the
equilibrium okay I know it's all of this
stuff in the middle of doing this is
just let me just annotate this really
quickly all of this stuff here is just X
minus the equilibrium okay that's all
those this is doing and I want my
equilibrium to change from x equals 0 to
x equals 1 the cart position at time 10
so I want to show that this is actually
moving the system over ok pretty simple
I've got some nonlinear dynamics I
measure the full state I subtract off
the nominal equilibrium position I run
it through my lqr gain matrix minus KX
that's all this is doing and I feed that
back as the input to my system okay and
if nothing went wrong I should be able
to run this so here I had to compile
this this code so you might want to
check that your compiler runs but all I
have to do is hit go and it simulates it
initializes it's running and it's done
so now I can open my scope my
oscilloscope it's a little hard to see
but basically what we have here are the
four variables in time and I'm just
going to kind of infer what I think
these variables are doing so this red
variable must be theta because it's
hanging out around pi okay at time 10
remember my I made my position walk from
0 to 1 so that's this yellow curve here
at time 10 my controller walks my system
over to position 1 and there's a little
dip in theta and a little bit of theta
dot and X dot right so essentially
what's happening is when it walks over
it probably kicks theta a little bit
maybe in this direction and then walks
over and stabilizes okay so we've
already written the script that
implements this lqr controller I'm just
showing you that it's possible to do in
Simulink okay that's all this is showing
is
in Simulink I get the same stabilization
of the theta equals PI and I'm able to
walk my system over let's say from cart
position zero to cart position one
really simple okay so that's all that
this is doing so now what we're going to
do is we're going to assume let's let's
not assume that we measure all of X
let's assume that we actually measure we
only measure some limited measurements Y
and so I'm going to do the following I'm
going to say well okay I want to know
what the truth is I'm going to have X
true coming off of this thing
but then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to essentially I'm just going to
pull up the whole Simulink window here
so essentially what I'm going to do is
I'm only going to measure CY okay so I'm
going to measure this is going to be a
little hard to to write and fit okay I'm
going to measure y equals CX then what
I'm going to do is I'm going to pipe
this into my common filter my big common
filter okay so this is y and remember my
common filter needs to know you you and
then the output of my common filter is
an estimate of the true full state X hat
which then goes into my lqr regulator
okay so this is this whole procedure is
the the linear quadratic Gaussian okay
this is called l qg linear quadratic
Gaussian it basically combines the
linear quadratic regulator and the calm
and filter for systems that have a an
output Y that's not the full state so
remember my lqr needs the full state but
if I'm only measuring Y and I'm not
measuring my full state I have to
estimate X and then I plug it into lqr
so this is a simulant code that does
basically the same thing and I'm just
going to walk you through it okay so
this hasn't modified much over my l QR
code I still have the same nonlinear
dynamic
I still have the same truth measurement
coming out but here this is my y equal C
times X so I'm only measuring and let's
actually make sure that this is yeah so
the gain matrix here I don't know if you
can see it but it says C so the matrix
here is C times X so the output is y
okay this block here is my common filter
so if I double click it you see that the
a matrix is my common filter dot a
matrix the B matrix is my common filter
dot B Coleman filter dot C Kalman filter
D so in the in the MATLAB window up here
I'm basically going to run all of this
code that builds my common filter in
case I'm going to define a C matrix of D
matrix and disturbance and noise
covariances I'm going to build my common
filter gain using either the lqe or lqr
command and then I'm going to actually
build a linear system called sis Kuhlman
filter that is this dynamical system
estimator I'm going to run all this code
now in memory there's a system called
sis Coleman filter and if I type it in
here this KF is this big see if I can
lift this it's this big common filter
system okay so it has an a matrix of b
matrix of c matrix and so on and so
forth and then if i type this KS a it
just pulls out the a matrix same with
dot b c and so on and so forth okay so
essentially what I'm doing is I'm taking
this big block here this calm and filter
block and I'm pretty sure if I wanted to
I could actually name it I could call
this column and filter okay and what I'm
doing is I'm just defining this the ABC
and D matrices of that system are sis KF
my common filter okay okay and then all
of this stuff looks a little weird
this is just doing the same thing I'm
subtracting off the equilibrium position
and I'm manually putting in a step so I
want to lock the cart over from position
zero to position one at time 10 okay so
that's just what we were doing before
this is just subtracting out the
equilibrium position and then is there
anything else I think that's it then I
run it through my so I get an estimate
of my full state X hat that goes into my
lqr and then that feeds back and
stabilizes my system okay so let's try
to run this ran super fast I double
click my scope and notice again almost
exactly the same response I have my my
system is stabilized in the vertical up
position because this theta is hanging
out around pi the yellow curve which is
my X position of my my cart is walking
from x equals 0 to x equals 1 at time 10
and notice that this is all working
purely based on a measurement only of
the yellow signal so all I measuring is
this yellow cart position and how I'm
kicking the system and I'm estimating
using this common filter theta X X dot
and theta dot okay so this is really
cool that we're able to build up this
estimator and when we build this
estimator we're able to combine it with
lqr to stabilize an unstable system okay
so that's the whole idea behind LQG this
full design this sensor based feedback
of an unstable system now if you played
around with this a little more you'd
find that if I added a lot of noise to
this measurement or if I added a lot of
disturbances to system it's actually a
lot more sensitive when I combine these
two okay so the combined system is more
sensitive to noise and it's more
sensitive to disturbances and this is a
general issue with these linear
quadratic gaussian controllers is that
they can be kind of non robust to no
lies to disturbances and so that's
something we'll talk about later but I
just wanted you to see how these pieces
combine okay
thank you